qui êtes-vous au marché je suis un
espèce de citoyens du monde qui est je
suis un joueur de bridge j'aime les
chevaux de course et je crois que je
fais du cinéma seulement en amateur je
voudrais vraiment plus être un joueur de
cartes caractère mais omar sharif n'est
pas seulement joueurs de bridge ni même
turfistes il a avoué avec humour jean
daniel simon
marc sharif vous avez des chevaux qui
courent ici non pas ici sur les
trotteurs à celle des chevaux qui
courent
le plat les obstacles quand elle chante
et
le cgpcs sage suis né à alexandrie
et mon père voulait que je fasse du
commerce avec lui j'ai essayé pendant
deux ans et j'ai trouvé ça aurait
vraiment horrible quand même je trouvais
que tout le monde était des voleurs
presque si on si on a vraiment sion les
très très très stricte sur la morale on
s'aperçoit que tous les commerçants sont
des voleurs sont bien obligés de l'être
je crois mais et moi ça me plaisait pas
du tout et j'ai je vendais tout à fait
exprès ou père me renvoie à vos besoins
il m'a envoyé dans sa peur du cinéma du
théâtre
joe ou est souvent mais nous nous y
invite
jeunes
dois je crois que ça va être un succès
de succès testing savez un grand succès
de stival de cannes
mais du point de vue financier ça va
être un désastre
donc personne m'avait demandé de
travailler ensuite quand je suis devenu
peut-être si vous voulez dans le mois
rien j'ai passé par une période où je
suis devenu presque fait c'est à dire
que commencer à croire que j'étais un un
demi dieu que ce que les gens voulaient
me toucher juste alors j'avais 22 ans je
pensais que c'était extraordinaire que
j'étais une personne export et pendant
deux ans d'abord je jouais très mal
après ça puisque je jouais au lieu de de
faire ce que j'avais fait pour avoir mon
succès cet été de ne pas jouer au début
et ensuite je faisais ce que je pensais
que les stars doivent faire c'est à dire
ne pas aller au studio que quand ils en
ont envie
ne pas écouter le metteur en scène il
faire ce qu'on veut faire et j'ai eu
trois échecs terrible et qui est pendant
deux ans je ne trouvais plus de travail
et à ce moment là j'ai je devrais appris
si vous voulez un peu l'humidité et je
ne pense pas plus jamais de retomber
dans cette danse est faute
mesnil avait vu une photo de moi
quelqu'un savait même pas si je parlais
et il m'avait demandé de venir faire des
essais n'hésitez pas qu'il avait déjà
engagé un autre acteur pour jouer ce
rôle dans leurs habits le rôle de shérif
en mai 2010 n'était pas content parce
que cet acte aurait des yeux bleus et
lui voulaient quelqu'un qui est vraiment
l'air de ce qu'est ce que personne âgée
t&d qui m'a vu descendre de l'avion dans
le désert il avait été tout de suite
convaincu que c'était moi qui les
chevaux
salah videmment ça a été un grand succès
ça m'a apporté beaucoup de travail et
puis alors j'ai docteur jivago qui a été
vraiment le tournant de ma carrière en
réalité parce que c'est à ce moment là
c'est après seulement après leur fait
jivago que je me suis aperçu que j'étais
devenu quelqu'un
d'important parce que chaque fois que je
venais à paris j'avais chaque jour dans
la poche des invitations de chic pour
aller chez tout le monde
les gens de tout genre de société
sa cote
à la nuit des généraux avec ce n'était
pas possible
quand je demande de prêt ces jeux croyez
pas
je demandais à faire les essais pour moi
convaincre moi même que c'était
président égyptien qui vraiment rôle de
l'outaouais
j'ai fait ensuite un fou avec sophia
loren que les pas sortir encore en
italie avec encore audi et je crois que
ce sera très bien c'est un conte de fées
et se passer actuellement qui se passe
non donc qui se passe au 16e siècle
mais lui comme c'est un metteur en scène
très à gauche et l'a employé comme c'est
un conte de fée pour faire ce pour dire
ce qu'il a à dire vous êtes marié je
suis je suis marié je suis séparé de ma
femme depuis deux ans maintenant j'ai un
fils qui a 10 ans qui est fait à
l'écologiste et qui était dans le
docteur jivago et qui est en train de
tourner un film maintenant sans que je
le sache je ne savais pas et il avait
disparu pendant dix jours on ne trouvait
plus à l'école
vous prête une certaine carrière de
séducteur aussi
est-ce que les exactes dans tous ça je
ne sais pas du tout je crois que c'est
autour de la publicité je crois quand
j'ai commencé quand j'ai fait lawrence
d'arabie par le fait que je joue le rôle
d'un chèque et compense ce joueur
valentino dans le rôle du chèque on a
tout de suite commencé à faire des des
rapprochements mais je crois que ce
n'est pas vrai du tout et que ya pas
vraiment maintenant de séducteur dans ce
sens comme la veille les séducteurs
avant les gens qui jouer les séducteurs
ça n'existe plus moi j'ai ma vie
sentimentale view blake est aussi
remplie que la vôtre mais pas plus
on
pour gagner ma vie aussi bien jean cot
cherchant du bridge je comprendrais le
cinéma
vous avez joué là cette course j'ai joué
j'ai perdu
non